please welcome lamorin morris
oh hey oh hey how you doing how you
folks doing
i was so excited to talk to you
because you are um from chicago
and they surprised everybody with uh
dying the
river green yes 100
that is a good old-fashioned chicago
tradition which
i don't agree with to be quite honest
with you um
people jump in there people may or may
not drink the water and i'll be quite
honest i'm not sure if it's sanitary
enough for me to put my body inside of
it
you know what i mean it might actually
be booze in the water
and i think that's when you see people
raging the street that's usually what
happens people are raging in the streets
you know they're raging here in new york
too there's like people wasted at 8 45
in the morning it's fantastic
that's just new york
um i wanted to ask you about because i
have
young kids in school right now and then
they're in home school and
i'm just going to be super honest we're
all struggling really bad
and i was um really affected by the
story
uh you had two different teachers who
encouraged you with comedy in chicago
will you please tell me those stories
because as a parent i'm like
i loved these and it meant a lot to me
because we really need our teachers
oh yeah um so you know in high school
like most kids
i want to be there not at all uh i my
imagination was all over the place i was
telling jokes my
i was kind of you know i didn't know
where my outlet was
necessarily you know i was i was i was
in math class you know of all classes
and um my teacher robert dobes
bob dobes he he really encouraged my
behavior if you will by allowing me to
get five minutes before class
i would talk i would make jokes i mean
another buddy sometimes
chris page and i remember we would just
kind of go back and forth and the trick
in his class was to always talk about
baseball because his son
played baseball so we figure if we could
have enough jokes about baseball or talk
to him about baseball long enough
in 45 minutes the period will be over
and we didn't really learn a thing and
we'd be like
great and then we'd be on to the next
subject yeah so
he he definitely encouraged it however
it was always followed by
um also the morning after your five
minutes you got to go to detention
right exactly you know so the detention
instructor
gave me a pamphlet to a place called
second city and said
you know you need an outlet for all this
energy have you heard have you thought
about doing comedy for a living
i don't know what that was i didn't know
what doing comedy for a living was you
know i'm from chicago so
you kind of you know didn't have a lot
of those
those examples right in front of you you
know so second city happened to be the
place where
um i kind of began my career
and lamorne uh will you mention just a
few alumni
from second city for everyone watching
i mean you got uh you got amy poehler
is the you know i mean the list goes on
and on and on you've got
i know brian it's one of the most
important comedic
institutions uh that we have in our
country
um there's the groundlings there's
second city these are the places where
all yes ucb all of your favorite
comedians
really come from and get their start
together
it goes way back too it goes way back oh
yeah [ __ ] volusia
yeah well i'm very grateful to that
teacher
and lamorin in women's history month
your mom
worked for the usps for how many years
the mourn
well almost 40 years almost 40 years um
she's the most fantastic person that
i've ever met in my entire life
that's where i kind of that's why i get
everything that you see from i get my
energy from my mother
she studied theater back in the day um i
what if i'm sending a package somewhere
you know she would give me a side eye if
it's not
you know united states postal service
i'm sitting in fedex she got beat
she got a real problem with me well
please tell your mom that we have a
reoccurring segment on this show called
dear drew that's all about the love of
the usps
and snail mail please oh very very nice
oh she'll she'll love it
and lamorn you have so many things going
on
everybody loves you from your longevity
run on the hit show new girl
and then you do this show called
woke on hulu i was fortunate enough to
watch it it's incredible will you tell
us
about that show because i would love to
hear it described in your words
well woke is about a cartoon
a cartoonist who's kind of on the brink
of success
but like a lot of people reality smacks
him in the face and in his case reality
comes in the form of
a little bit of brutality you know
a little bit of he got roughed up by the
police i'll just say
and he's suffering a little ptsd from it
so it's kind of
about this guy's journey from being just
the
kind of run-of-the-mill cartoonist to a
outspoken activist if you will
yeah i think it's so incredible
uh your show and i'm so congratulations
on it getting picked up for a season too
thank you by the way speaking of your
number one in the country podcast
hang on because we have a new graphic
for you and i'm really excited
lamar and you're the first person we're
doing this but will you
break down your number one in the
country podcast on something we're
calling
the download
[Music]
tell us about unwanted which you created
so unwanted is an action comedy it's an
action comedy that you can listen to in
your ear holes
and it is one of the greatest homages to
to the the films that i love the most
uh from the 80s and uh it's about two
guys on a mission trying to catch
the most dangerous woman on the planet
but what they don't know
is that they are way in over their heads
and
she makes life uh a living hell for
these two
um all while they're trying to cash in
on this million dollar reward so
um i'm excited i'm excited for folks to
listen to it i have to say
there is so much sound editing and
effects
and you really fill out the whole world
and it feels like a very rich and full
elaborate world
that you get enveloped by it kind of it
kind of takes us back to those days
where families would get around the
radio and listen to
listen to stories and back then folks
didn't know if it were if
if an alien invasion was really
happening or not you know so
this is a kind of a way to immerse
yourself into a feature film or a
television show
all while you know keeping your eyes on
the road or
you know doing something around the
house it's great i see why it's number
one it is completely different
you